[Music]
this is kim jong-un
ruler of north korea
he's just 36 years old
but he commands the world's fourth
largest military
he has nuclear weapons
and his family has ruled over their
people using violence and terror for
over 70 years
but kim is a man torn between two worlds
the traditions of his brutal communist
past
and the need to become a legitimate
modern leader
that is his dilemma
am i going to come out and become
a cleaner softer dictator
or am i going to continue to retain this
criminal regime that i inherited from my
grandfather and my father
and that dilemma you know what it could
be the end of the king dynasty
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
kim jong-un is only the third man to
rule north korea
he is following his grandfather
and father
in the role of supreme leader
they rule over their people
as gods
[Music]
in the tenth year of his rule kim
jong-un is at a crossroads
he's a dictator with a decision to make
[Music]
should he try to drag north korea into
the modern world and become a legitimate
country but risk losing his grip on
power
or should he continue to run a rogue
state like his grandfather and father
before him
if i compared to a movie i would say
it's godfather three and that's when
michael corleone wants to become a
legitimate businessman and head of a
business conglomerate
out from the the shadows of the mafia
regime that he inherited
but without the mafia state
the kim regime would not function why
because it is under heavy sanctions the
only way that it can make hard currency
is by illicit trade
the north korean regime is in many
respects a huge criminal cartel
guns
drugs
counterfeit cash
and cyber crime
bring in an estimated 2 billion a year
for kim to spend
that's his personal piggy bank
and that is the way the kim jong-un
regime is sustained
recently kim has shown signs of
modernizing
he's been stepping out with his first
lady
and meeting other world leaders
but in 2017 he was dragged back into his
family business
[Music]
this is his elder half-brother kim
jong-nam
who was overlooked for succession
he left north korea for a quiet life in
china
surfacing on camera from time to time to
speak out against the regime
but then it seemed kim jong-nam crossed
a line
during the course of my reporting i was
told by a person
with good connections to the
intelligence community in the united
states that kim jong-nam had in fact
been an informant to the caa and was
supplying information about kim jong-un
to them
[Music]
these cctv images show him meeting his
suspected handler
a fascinated news media shadowed his
every move
he still had very good connections to
the regime so for the cia to be able to
recruit kim jong-nam as an informer and
to get whatever information he had it
would have been a huge deal for them
this would also have been considered
very treasonous by kim jong-un
it seems the time had come for kim to
deal with his older brother
[Music]
february 13 2017.
kuala lumpur international airport
kim jong-un's brother enters the
terminal unaware the two female
assassins are also at the airport
[Music]
now for the first time on television one
of the assassins tells her full
extraordinary story
[Music]
[Music]
it begins with her being recruited by a
man who claimed to be a tv producer
[Music]
for months kim jong-un's agents groomed
city and another young woman to ambush
unsuspecting members of the public
and smothered their faces with cosmetic
creams and what they thought were hidden
camera show stunts
city's handler arranges a meeting at a
cafe in the airport
there she is to receive details of the
target
[Music]
uh
m
this time it isn't baby oil
but a deadly nerve agent
as kim jong-un's brother heads to his
flight the two women make their move
japanese
seeking help kim jong-nam heads for the
airport's medical facility
so at this point kim jong-nam is in the
infirmary and he is behind the door
and this is where this image gets very
scary there's a gentleman in all black
walking
near this door okay and he's got a rolly
suitcase
he's checking in to make sure that kim
jong-nam is receiving medical treatment
this is one of the operatives
it's a very elaborate operation it's
very old school
the operation plays out like a cold war
spy caper
there are lookout men
a chemist to handle the nerve agent
a getaway driver
and a team leader
codenamed grandpa
the young women have no idea what
they've done
[Music]
they are soon apprehended by the local
malaysian police
then
the trial creates shock waves around the
world
she's been charged for the most serious
crime in the country the crime of murder
for the offense of mother there's only
one punishment and that is death by
hanging
soon the chemist of the gang is also
apprehended
he is caught on camera getting his story
straight with north korean embassy
officials
this video evidence helped to build a
picture of a ruthless political
assassination
both women were released after spending
two years in prison
[Music]
[Music]
kim jong-un's troublesome older brother
was no more
kim jong-un's half-brother
died in such a terrible
humiliating way on camera and kim
probably was very pleased that he was
able to watch all of this
[Music]
amid sobering scenes broadcast around
the world kim jong-nam's body is brought
back to north korea
it's accompanied by the same men spotted
in the airport on the day he was
murdered
it was absolutely to send a message to
do in such a public way to everybody
in north korea and elsewhere that
kim will find you
[Music]
to understand kim jong-un
it's helpful to know the world he grew
up in
[Music]
deep beneath the surface of north korea
his father created an elaborate hidden
kingdom that his children inhabited
north korea has a separate parallel
geography that exists
outside of anything north korean
citizens would know about
it's a secret network that includes
roads
railways and tunnel systems
it's a way of concealing kim's
whereabouts from spy satellites
[Music]
[Music]
currently we're looking at kim jong-un's
kang dong vip complex
kang dong complex is one of the favorite
complexes of the kim family
kim jong-un spent a lot of time there as
a child
so this is a portal tunnel
we can see the tunnel entrance
there's a road that goes under the
tadong river
so what kim jong-un could do is instead
of going across that bridge uh he would
go through that tunnel and that tunnel
would take him under the tadang river
into tunnels under mountains to some
unknown locale and i call it the road to
nowhere
it's believed there are some eight
thousand tunnels in north korea
reaching up to a thousand feet below the
surface
some tunnels are thought to extend more
than 30 miles including an emergency
escape route into china
so basically kim jong-un can work in his
office
take an elevator to a sub-basement level
get into a small motorcade drive
underground
and that explains a lot about kim
jong-un's personality
kim jong-un grew up like that
this has been his entire life
the early years of kim jong-un's
childhood indoctrinated him in the ways
of the kim dynasty
kim jong-un grew up in this extremely
dysfunctional paranoid secretive family
it was impossible for kim jong-un to be
a normal child
[Music]
he was named the little general
he had a real cult pistol
you know he had real generals bowing to
him
his father was kim jong-il
one of the most notorious dictators in
history
a man with a passion for banquets
cognac
and bond movies
kim jong-il was generally paranoid
around this period of time for kim
jong-un
there's a lot of restrictions on his
movements and activity
and they have to bring in playmates
well you think they bring in other seven
or eight-year-old children but you're
you're starting to talk about 30 or 40
year old bodyguards and so kim jong-un
grows up very close to his bodyguards um
because these are his playmates
of all of kim jong-il's bodyguards only
one is known to have escaped north korea
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
the bodyguard also remembers the current
ruler of north korea
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
today kim jong-un still surrounds
himself with these bodyguards
he has expanded the program
adding an elite unit to handle internal
threats
the guys that protect him despite the
fact that they wear suits these people
are very similar to sas or navy seals in
terms of their skills and training
they inspect his food if you had a sack
of rice that sack of rice is scrutinized
and inspected for any irregular grains
and so every bag of rice
is a perfect bag of rice
they bring his toilet there is a
portable toilet
because they don't want a foreign
intelligence agency getting a hold of
his feces and then analyzing the blood
contents for whatever diseases he might
have
so kim jong-un's psychology is deeply
rooted in his father's totalitarian
regime
but there is another side to kim's
experience
his school days
in the west
[Music]
kim jong-un is changing his country with
a new style of leadership
it includes photo ops
north korean style
many think he's been influenced by the
time he spent as a teenager in
switzerland
[Music]
living in the care of his maternal aunt
and uncle
kim jong-un attended a regular public
school in bern
my name is nikola kovachovic and
well i know kim jong-un
from my school in switzerland
so
this is pretty much
as i remember him
wearing a
typical
sports outfit very american
he was wearing chicago balls shirts
shorts and michael jordan shoes we were
quite impressed by that
we were playing basketball and un
was looking for people to play with
i'll never forget him with a you know
cheeky smile on his face you know at the
basketball court
we pretty much just played constantly
he was very
very passionate you could clearly see
that he wants to win he was very good
very quick
he was on a completely different level
than
you might think
by looking at the pictures from today we
all liked having him in our team
we did have
interesting
chats about north korea
there was one occasion where
i was just asking something like how is
it there and i remember him saying that
north korea is
is very very advanced it's going to be a
big player in the future
you can definitely say that he was proud
of his country
[Music]
he really enjoyed kind of the life of
being a rich kid in europe
he saw nba games in paris he went off
skiing in the swiss alps
[Music]
but back in north korea there are
changes inside the family
kim jong-un's mother is dying of cancer
which means kim's aunt and uncle are
about to lose their connection to the
dynasty
fearing they may be cast aside they
decide to act
[Music]
slipping out of the house under cover of
darkness
his aunt and uncle take refuge in the
u.s embassy
[Music]
claiming political asylum
they are spirited away to a military
base in germany
kim jong-un was at home
they did not say goodbye
they left him in the middle of the night
it must have been an extremely traumatic
experience for kim jong-un
to be abandoned like that
[Music]
after debriefing by the cia
kim's aunt and uncle are given new
identities
flown to the u.s
and vanished from sight
[Music]
for the past 20 years they have been
living this completely anonymous life in
middle america
running a dry cleaners
so nobody knows their true identities
but journalist anna fifield tracked them
down
and arranged a meeting
i did not expect them to show up and
even like that morning when they called
to say they're on their way to where
we'd agreed to meet you know i was
surprised when they showed up
kim jong-un's aunt walked into the cafe
like i caught my breath because she
looked exactly like her sister kim
jong-un's mother
and i spent the entire weekend with them
talking about kim jong-un
about you know what he was like as a
child
and they described him as a normal kid
who was a little bit misunderstood
quite strange
i distinctly remember sitting on the
couch there with them at the time kim
jong-un was launching missiles
the projectile was fired from a 2000 ton
submarine and south korean military
officials believe the missile's rocket
booster did ignite
there's kim jong-un in a submarine
looking at missiles and the uncle said
they never say anything good about him
kim jong-un never completes his studies
in europe
age 17 he's recalled to north korea
[Music]
within a decade kim will find himself
the supreme leader of the most
repressive dictatorship on earth
he had lived in the west he had seen
freedom up close
so when he took over a lot of people
thought that he would be a reformer
and in fact early on in his tenure he
stood up and he said that north koreans
would never have to tighten their belts
again
so
if he wants to remain in power for
decades he can't just hold on like his
father did he really has to show an
improvement in the standard of living
inside north korea
kim jong-un is the only ruler of north
korea to have lived in the west
and his time in switzerland left its
mark on the supreme leader
[Music]
kim jong-un
in the early years of his rule i saw
this desire for his country to be more
worldly for his people to be more
worldly
in 2012
kim ordered the construction of a ski
resort near his capital pyongyang
more alpine centers followed
complete with all the apres ski parks
[Music]
i was one of the first
foreigners to visit
a little piece of switzerland in north
korea
i could see the wheels turning in kim
jong-un's head
around that time there was a lot of hope
and speculation
[Music]
that this would be a moment for a very
different type of north korea
[Applause]
[Music]
kim builds his citizens theme parks and
shopping malls
all in the name of north korea's bright
economic future
so we see the development of things like
amusement parks
high-end restaurants department stores
all of these things are also part of the
kim brand
it's designed to show his people that
kim is going to move the country forward
[Music]
in the drive to rebrand his kingdom kim
has an ally
his celebrity wife
ri soldier was a famous singer in north
korea
she would be instantly recognizable to
any north korean who's ever watched tv
[Music]
in 2018
kim changes his wife's official title
from comrade
to first lady
she has a very distinct role
she's very much like the kate middleton
of north korea she is there to kind of
humanize her husband but also the two of
them together are supposed to be a kind
of modern
aspirational couple they're showing the
future of north korea
leading north korea into the future
presents kim with another challenge
in a digital age shaped by the internet
and social media kim is under pressure
to ensure his people aren't left behind
if he's going to rule for decades to
come he has to build his loyalty base
he wants to
woo his generation
so he started experimenting with
internet access
uh expanding cell phone access those are
all monumental changes for a country
like north korea
recently kim has gone further
authorizing north korea's very own
social media stars
[Music]
this is where a big concert is going to
take place
the occasion is to celebrate to youtube
[Music]
they even have their own influencers now
[Music]
what they are portraying is a socialist
fairyland
it's just absolutely amazing
and it's so carefully cultivated
[Music]
their role is to seduce people
to fall in love with the country
it's a smart strategy
but on the other hand
access to information is one of the most
dangerous things for a leader like kim
jong-un
because if people see what life is like
outside north korea
the illusion could be broken
and that of course for kim jong-un
is terrifying
for 75 years the kim family has relied
on strength and terror for their
survival
[Music]
as kim jong-un attempts to transform
himself from god-like tyrant to an
approachable human leader
he needs backup within the family to
maintain the dynasty's grip on power
but who can he rely on
2001
kim jong-un's father takes a training
across russia
the russian ambassador is having
conversations with him he asks him about
succession and he asked kim jong-il who
are your favorites his successor and kim
jong-il said well
my sons are all idol blockheads
okay it's my daughters that have the
heart
and intellect and mindset to be in
politics
[Music]
born four years after kim jong-un in
1988
kim yo zhang is nicknamed
the sweet princess
until the death of her father in 2011
kim yo-jong's existence was a closely
guarded secret even inside north korea
[Music]
after kim jong-il died
with the succession of her brother
there was probably a conversation
do you want to do this do you want to be
involved in the nitty-gritty
of north korean politics
some people don't have the ice in their
veins to do it some people do
she said yes and that's where we find
ourselves today
quietly kim yo zhang rose through the
ranks to become her brother's propaganda
chief
[Music]
in 2018 he deployed his sister on her
first foreign assignment
a mission
inside enemy territory
it was a really huge occasion when kim
yo-jong arrived into south korea
because she was the only member of the
kim family who had arrived in the south
since the korean war ended in 1953
so it was a really big deal
the occasion was the winter olympics
dubbed the peace olympics as athletes
from north and south korea competed
together for the first time
there was an ice hockey game where the
two korean teams joined together as one
and she was in the stands in the vip
section
i was able to walk down to see her in
the flesh
she was very kind of enigmatic
she always had this kind of sphinx-like
smile on her face
[Music]
she said very little
so she became a real object of
fascination
at that time amongst south koreans
[Music]
but kim's sister hasn't just come south
of the border to show face
with the eyes of the world on her she
opens peace talks with the south korean
leadership
[Music]
kim yo-jong
is becoming indispensable to the family
firm she is the one that approves all
the media and press and writing that
comes out in english in north korea
any piece of paper and any email that
gets directed to kim jong-un is most
likely viewed by her
and that's a critical thing to have
[Music]
the sweet princess isn't only kim
jong-un's right-hand woman
recently she's become a deadly player in
her own right
i believe there have been people that
have been shot on the orders of kim
yo-jong that's kim yo-jong psychology
she's a shark
[Music]
in a sign of her growing power
in 2020
kim jong-un promotes his sister
over his own generals to the highest
level of the public bureau
[Music]
[Music]
kim yo-jong's prominence has
dramatically increased in 2020.
[Music]
the thing that's most striking is she's
gone from a role of being in the
background to actually being a voice of
the regime
kim's sister goes on the attack
threatening south korean activists who
continue to drop propaganda leaflets
over the border
[Music]
she is the only individual who has been
able to put out
a personal opinion in north korean state
media even the leader himself very
rarely is going to express any sort of
personal opinion
this means that she has a unique special
and privileged role in the north korean
regime
[Music]
amid rising tensions between north and
south korea
in june 2020 kim yo zhang sends south
korea a message
blowing up the government complex used
for talks between the two sides
korean experts say the explosion was
designed to cement the growing power of
pyongyang leader kim jong-un's younger
sister kim yo-jong in recent years state
media has referred to her as a central
party cadre indicating her tightening
grip on power this year she took over
some of her brother's roles in party
affairs and foreign relations sources
suggest she is now the real power holder
in pyongyang
now she is continually even outside of
her actual rank and position bashing
south korea and the united states
this is a role that normally is reserved
only for the supreme leader
it's classic north korean provocation
[Music]
it seems kim is on his way to resolving
his dilemma
how to modernize the country without
losing control
the answer
a dual dictatorship
his sister keeps order with the
traditional tools
fear aggression and discipline
while kim reinvents himself as a modern
politician
with a kinder gentler image
we have to remember when we're talking
about kim jong-un
his main aspiration and his main focus
as a leader right now is resetting the
north korean political system so that he
becomes more above the fray
and doesn't necessarily have to sign off
on any individual public execution
kim jong-un does not want to be seen as
a person who criticizes and bad-mouth
you know other leaders
so he leaves the dirty work in some
respects for kim yo-jong to do
kim yo-jong is the bad cop kim jong-un
gets to look like a cool-headed leader
but in his bid to secure the dynasty and
hang on to power kim is only halfway to
the
to transform north korea into a truly
modern society he must step onto the
global stage
and bring an end to seven decades of
isolation from the outside world
[Music]
[Music]
you